-You're always so fun,
and I love when you're funny.
And we always joke around
every time you're here.
But this movie, "Fatherhood,"
is a beautiful story.
-It's based on a true story of
a guy named Matt Logelin.
And the story is about
a man whose life
got flipped upside down.
You know, he lost his wife
after delivering a baby
and was left with, you know, the
idea of raising a child
by himself
after suffering, you know,
one of the darkest moments
in his life.
And there was a high level of
doubt in what he could do,
if he could do, and rather than
giving up, you know,
he had to figure out a way
to kind of bear down
and stick with what life
has thrown at him
and make the best of it.
And in this case,
for me to take on the role,
it gave me the opportunity
to show a black father
in a positive light.
You know, for some time on
the screen, on TV,
if we're not getting out of jail
or on drugs or off drugs --
You know,
there's a significant struggle
behind the image
of a black father.
And I said,
"This is an opportunity
just to put it in
the space of positivity."
And that was my reason
for taking on the role
and also challenging
myself to --
you know, to go a little
deeper into acting.
It's a serious story.
It's emotional.
And it has its waves.
So I'm excited about the journey
that I'm about to
take my audience on.
-Your co-star in the movie
is a baby.
Now, clearly,
you can't use an actual baby
for all the hours of filming.
So you had a --
-Says who?
Says who?
-No, no, that's a fact.
-No, it's not.
-Yes, it is.
-No, it's not a fact.
-Yes, it is a fact.
-We had a brilliant baby --
we had a brilliant baby
that I worked with,
and this baby was relentless.
This baby worked hours.
Hours. This baby was pulling
14-hour days.
-No, no, no. That is not true.
-I've never seen
anything like it.
-No, Kevin,
that was a fake baby.
I know this for a fact --
that you are not allowed to work
for this many hours with a baby.
What you were acting with
was a doll.
-This is ridiculous!
What you're saying
is ridiculous!
To say that I would work with --
As a thesbian.
I'm a thesbian.
To suggest that I would work --
-Thespian.
Thespian, not a thesbian.
-Don't you tell me -- Don't you
tell me what it is.
For you to suggest that,
you've got some nerve, Jimmy,
to think that that was
a fake baby.
You better look at the tape.
I only work with real babies.
It's in my contract, buddy.
I'm Kevin "The Real Baby
Work-with-er" Hart.
That's who I am.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's who I am.
That's who I am, Jimmy, okay?
-I want to say
you did a great job
in this film, by the way.
I did see it,
and you were great.
And I want to show
everyone a clip.
Here is Kevin Hart
in "Fatherhood."
Take a look at this.
-I don't know
if it's normal or not,
but it's two different kinds.
She can either hit you
with a streamer --
that's when
it's all put together
and it's a little solid and
it's a direct hit --
or she'll buckshot you,
and that's -- that's that spay.
It's a quick whop.
I need help.
I need the crying to stop.
How do I make the crying stop?
-Okay.
Um, my oldest had colic for
the first couple of months.
-What's colic?
-It's when babies cry for hours
on end without any reason,
till you feel like your eyes
are about to pop out.
-I gave the baby colic.
-No, that's -- that's not
how colic works.
-It's 'cause I'm not
washing my hands
and I'm just touching the baby.
That's how I gave the baby
colic, probably.
-You don't give a baby colic.
It's more of a digestive thing.
-That's a relief.
-Kevin Hart, everybody!
That's how you do it
right there.
"Fatherhood" begins streaming
on Netflix on June 18th.
Pre-order his book,
"Marcus Makes a Movie."
Thank you again for being here.